Theo hạn thông tần Rhoi Tư sàng ngày 11 tháng 6, chỉ quyền Mỹ y giới thời tổng thủ đúng
năng trăm đang xem sẽ bổ xung thêm 3 mì sau cu ra vào giành xa khạn chế công dân
dập cảnh vào Mỹ trong bối cảnh sát lệnh cảm công dân từ 2 cu ra của chính thức có hiệu
lực từ đầu tháng ngày. Đây là một trong lựa trên dịch sẽ chặt kẹp sát nhập cư
nhằm vào về an ninh cu ra và chúng cú bố theo một bức điện mọi bộ dọn ngoại trường
mắt gồn rubio ki. Bộ ngoại rong Mỹ đã sát định 3 mì sau cu ra ở đây lòng ác
với lý dò bao gồm cứ hợp tác trong việc cấp dẩy tờ trình thân đá tinh cầy.
Không tiếp nhận công dân bị Mỹ trục xuất và tình trạc công dân liều chủ của hạn visa.
Một số trường hợp có liên quan đến vui cơ cùng bố, phát mồn bài sâu thái hoặc trong Mỹ.
Mồn ngoại rong Mỹ cảnh báo cán nước này phải có bịnh pháp khắc phục trong vòng sống mấy ngày.
Nếu không sẽ bị xem sát cầm tỏa mộ học một phần công dân nhập cạnh.
Giang sát gồm nhiều nước châu Phi, châu Á và châu đại dương, như cảm phù chia, xí rí, u gàn đà,
lệnh cảm hoàn toàn công dân từ 12 cư ra, chủ yếu ở Trung Đông và Châu Phi,
như Iran, Somali, Sù Đăng, Mở Yê Mênt,
ngoài ra công dân từ bánh nước khác trong đó Covid-19 và lào cũng bị hạn chế nhập cảnh.
Tổ thống trọng bía t dành xanh này có thể đủ điều trình như các cư ra cạnh thiện hật tác.
Truyên xanh mới, được đưa ra trong bối cảnh phong chào biểu tình phản đồ chút xuất,
như cơ, đang diễn ra với quy mồn lớn và phức tác, tạng nhiều thành phố lớn.
Các nước Mỹ tập biệt là tạng lúc, Angela S, mạng, California,
nơi chính quyền đã phải điều động vệ viên cuối ra và truyên quân lúc chiến tới hỗ trợ.